[Music]  this you folks need to turn around  pretty bad accident up ahead anything we  can do your doctor or something or  something nice doll that's what you  think day work the evil is contained how  could you not tell me you're babysitting  your horns tonight yeah it will be back  early tomorrow morning don't your  parents keep any creepy stuff around you  keep it all locked away in a room it's  not good for anyone to go in there my  dad says that everything in there is  either haunted cursed or he's done some  ritualistic practice what's that this  area now they put coins went over the  eyes of the dead so he could take their  cells  what about the doll that's in there and  about she's in a case for a reason  Anabelle mr. bacon father spirits  [Music]  mrs. Martha okay something is happening  inside your house and we're not really  sure what to do can I speak to Annabelle  I'm sorry you need to give her a soul  dear  [Music]